le retour des enfants à l'école par
exemple est une sorte de test grandeur
nature
on voit bien à quel point la france est
divisée aujourd'hui sur le retour des
enfants à l'école certains disent qu'ils
c'est une folie sa relance et l'épidémie
d'autres ne maintiennent que les enfants
ne se transmettent pas entre le cornac
virus encore moins à l'égard des adultes
et que donc il n'y a aucun danger
on va pouvoir voir on va constater
puisque en france les élus les enfants
vont retourner à l'école et que dans
d'autres pays
il n'en est pas question vous n'avez pas
l'impression que là on va enfin savoir
on a un test grandeur nature
absolument mais voyez ça montre c'est un
exemple l'excellent parce qu'ils
montrent qu'il ya un conflit entre taux
tombe à deux temporalités et la
temporalité de la recherche comme je les
dis les protocoles selon fo de la
statistique font des études fine ça
prend du temps on peut accélérer les
protocoles nos vocations placé parce que
si on s'en passe on scie la branche sur
laquelle la science est assise et et on
perd toute crédibilité
et puis les politiques doivent prendre
des décisions urgentes et ses décisions
ils les prennent en méconnaissance de
cause puisque les scientifiques leur
disent 'voilà ce conseil voilà ce qu'on
sait pas on peut pas encore dire et il
faut quand même décidé et donc il ya une
sorte de pari qu'a fait et la reprise de
l'école c'est une forme de pari
on verra à la fin qui avait raison ils
sont que des pays où ça se passe bien on
verra qui a raison mais je pense que là
pour le coup il faut reconnaître aux
scientifiques et aux politiques
justement le fait qu'ils sont
responsables des décisions ils peuvent
pas se prêter derrière un conseil
scientifique
si fait que le conseil scientifique il a
un rôle un rôle à un peu ambigu ce
travers alain supiot qui est professeur
professeur au collège de france dit le
conseil scientifique relations sont en
général elle doit assurer un service de
phares et balises phare parce que elle
doit éclairer les responsables
politiques qui prennent les décisions et
doivent les assumer et de balises parce
qu'il faut aussi qu'ils signalent les
écueils des périls les tempêtes
peut-être qui menace et que les
politiques devront prendre en compte
dans la façon décidée le voit bien que
les directives assez subtil
l'ong on n'imaginerait pas eu des hommes
politiques des styles sans tenir compte
de ce qui est su par les scientifiques à
propos d'un virus comme ça
[Musique]